[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france
au sommaire aujourd'hui la lutte contre
le vih est la maladie du sida plus de 30
ans après le début de la pandémie
la victoire n'est toujours pas à
l'horizon et cela malgré certaines
avancées majeures
alors où en est-on actuellement dans ce
combat contre le vih
donald trump se donne dix ans pour
éradiquer complètement le sida un
objectif plus ambitieux que se fixe
également le royaume uni et la france
pourtant cette promesse n'est pas
nouvelle elle prend ses racines dans la
résolution onusienne adoptée à
l'unanimité par l'assemblée générale de
l'onu en 2015 est-ce pourtant un
objectif réaliste presque 38 millions de
personnes sont actuellement porteuses du
vih dans le monde et seulement près de
deux tiers d'entre elles ont un accès au
traitement antirétroviral cependant ce
qui donne de l'espoir c'est que depuis
2015 le nombre de nouvelles personnes
contaminées par le vih a diminué de 10%
afin de maintenir ce progrès le nude
sida a besoin de beaucoup d'argent
il pourrait manquer au programme onusien
cette année presque 7 milliards de
dollars nécessaires pour la lutte contre
le vih une baisse de la contribution
américaine au programme anti vhc proposé
par donald trump en mars 2019
mais le congrès bloc cette initiative
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur le vih qui malgré des
efforts titanesques reste aujourd'hui un
vaincu c'est le blitz les premiers cas
clair du sida sont observés en 1981 aux
états unis deux ans plus tard les
scientifiques identifient le virus de
l'immunodéficience humaine qui est à
l'origine de la maladie depuis près de
75 millions de personnes ont été
touchées par le vih et 32 millions sont
décédées à cause du sida derniers stades
de l'infection
aujourd'hui le nombre de personnes
touchées par le vih restent alarmants
37,9 millions dans le monde
une urgence à laquelle le nu est appelée
à réagir en 2015 l'assemblée générale
adopte à l'unanimité le programme de
développement durable à l'horizon 2030
parmi les dix sept objectifs du
programme la victoire sur le sida d'ici
mais avant d'en parler le nude sida se
fixe d'abord l'objectif 90 90 90 il
prévoit qu'en 2020 90 % des porteurs du
virus connaîtront leur statut
séropositif 90% des malades
diagnostiqués auront accès aux
traitements et enfin 90% des personnes
sous traitement antirétroviral verront
leur charge virale supprimer or réaliser
ses objectifs cette année là semble très
improbable
parmi les obstacles principaux le manque
de financement bien sûr en 2018 quelques
19 milliards de dollars ont été
consacrés à des programmes de lutte
contre la maladie dans les pays à
faibles et moyens revenus
c'est un milliard de moins qu'en 2017 et
sept de moins que la somme jugée
nécessaire pour 2020 par ailleurs les
conflits armés la stigmatisation les
inégalités sociales limite fortement
l'accès au traitement antiviral
dans certains pays
bonne nouvelle le nombre de nouvelles
personnes contaminées par le vih est en
baisse est la proportion des malades
recevant un traitement antirétroviral
augmente mais la victoire contre ce
fléau est encore bien incertaine si le
nul parle de la fin du sida d'ici 2030
c'est que cet objectif optimiste a été
officiellement fixée par plusieurs pays
comme les etats unis la france ou le
royaume-uni mais est il vraiment
réaliste malgré certaines avancées les
situation reste alarmante
chaque année des centaines de milliers
de malades décèdent du sida à travers le
monde des millions de personnes
découvrent leur séropositivité au coeur
des préoccupations se trouve l'europe de
l'est et l'asie centrale où le sida
gagne progressivement du terrain en
afrique certains progrès sont accomplis
mais le nombre de personnes vivant avec
le vih reste très considérable plus de
25 millions autre point qui inquiète les
contributions des pays à l'onu sida
baisse d'un milliard de dollars en 2018
conflit violences inégalités e6 freine
considérablement les progrès l'autre
défi détail et la stigmatisation
le ms la qualifie même de principal
obstacle à la qualité des soins aux
malades du sida
alors quelles sont les solutions
envisagées pour limiter la progression
de cette maladie pourquoi malgré un
engagement international la fin du sida
n'était toujours pas visible à l'horizon
pour répondre à ces questions nous
rejoignons and sénéquier chercheuse
associée
aleris madame sénéquier bonjour mon
collègue
cette année c'est le délai final de
l'objectif des 3 90 cependant il est
loin d'être réalisé une percée est elle
encore possible
et qu'est ce qui a mis des bâtons dans
les roues de l'onu sida selon vous
j'avoue je pense que c'est important de
définir ce que c'est le 90 90 90 et 90%
des personnes qui ont le vih qui sont
conscients et qu'ils ont cette
connaissance justement d'être
séropositif dans ses 90 là à 90 %
auraient un accès aux traitements et 90
% de ces mêmes personnes là aurait une
charge virale indétectable sas
l'objectif justement pour permettre
cette l'éradication de cette épidémie
maintenant est ce que c'est encore
possible j'en dis qu'on a envie d'y
croire
et pourquoi finalement on en est encore
finale à se poser des questions
plusieurs choses on a évidemment les
problématiques de financement qu'on
verra probablement un petit peu plus
tard mais qui sont là aussi en termes de
santé et malheureusement le nerf de la
guerre
ensuite on a ce qu'on appelle les quick
win qui sont des des choses que l'on
peut faire et qui vont avoir un impact
très rapide et très important et ça
malheureusement dans certaines parties
du monde
on les a on les a déjà fait et du coup
les derniers les obstacles qui restent
encore sont les plus problématiques
parce que justement elles vont toucher
aux comportements et aux maillons
faibles finalement de toute épidémie
c'est à dire le facteur humain est le
facteur humain dans l'épidémie du sida
ont à plusieurs on a
les populations clés qui sont des cibles
de qui qui pourrait avoir un impact
encore important justement sur 7 sur
cette épidémie c'est à dire les
professionnels du sexe les consommateurs
de drogues injectables les hommes gais
et y en a on dit pas gai justement et
c'est justement une des problématiques
ont dit les hommes ayant des rapports
sexuels avec les hommes
les migrants les déplacés et les
réfugiés
et justement mon là dessus tout à leur
amène justement un autre problématique
justement du facteur humain c'est-à-dire
la stigmatisation et
la mise à l'écart justement des
personnes séropositives et de ses
populations que les russes temps et dans
certains pays il est encore aujourd'hui
impossible est inconcevable de se dire
homosexuels et donc c'est pour ça que la
sémantique dans les épidémies du vih
vont parler d' hommes ayant des rapports
sexuels avec des hommes pour que
justement ces personnes n'a pu
s'identifier dans ses politiques de
prévention et puisse si elle le souhaite
et si elles le peuvent aller voir un
professionnel de santé qui ne va pas
leur dire qu'ils sont hors la loi que
ils sont criminels et et que m en sers
emprisonné donc faut faire attention à
tous et ce facteur humain est très
important donc finalement on a un compte
à rebours une en reste onze mois on a
bien compris que l'argent ne suffira pas
mais il est nécessaire
on a surtout besoin d'une profonde prise
de conscience sur les déterminants de
cette épine des mineurs
l'inégalité et l'injustice aujourd'hui
renforcent cette épidémie et c'est là
dessus qu'il faut un qui veut travailler
aujourd'hui est donc cela nous amène à
l'autre question est ce que selon vous
pour mettre un terme au sida l'enjeu
serait plus scientifique sociétale ou
géopolitique il et multiplie les
scientifiques c'est certain parce qu'on
a besoin de nos recherches
médicamenteuse l'a déjà on a les
antirétroviraux qui sont passés de huit
comprimés par jour à prendre sur un seul
comprimé donc on est sur une vraie
amélioration on à l'arrivée de la prep
qui est ce traitement préventif
justement depuis la demi 2016
même les innovations à technologie qu'on
travaille avec l'intelligence
artificielle certains pays ont mis en
place jusqu'en des distributeurs
automatiques justement de ces
traitements préventifs
donc tout ça tout s'est tu cet enjeu
scientifique et
et d'innovation est très important pour
autant il est nécessaire mais il n'est
pas suffisant
après est-ce que je dirais enjeu
politique je pense que je parlerais
plutôt de d'enjeux sociétal où on a
cette nécessité de travailler sur les
droits sur la pauvreté sur l'acceptation
sur la sensibilisation des populations
d'ailleurs l'onu si damas ne s'y trompe
pas la présidente de l'onu sida a
dévoilé un petit peu les axes de sa
stratégie 2021-2030 où justement on
parle de droits de l'homme de travail
sur l'égalité ainsi de suite et ainsi de
suite
donc on y on a un enjeu scientifique
évident mais si on ne le chapeaute pas
de cet enjeu sociétal derrière
malheureusement il sera caduque
merci beaucoup madame sénéquier nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous retrouverons en fin
d'émission pour plus de détails sur la
question le 1er décembre 2019 à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida dont elle trump
confirme avoir fixé un objectif
ambitieux mettre fin au sida d'ici 2030
nous réaffirmons notre engagement à
mettre fin à l'épidémie de vih sida aux
états unis nous aurons éradiquer le sida
dans dix ans le programme a déjà
commencé et il n'est pas le seul paris
ou londres les dirigeants du monde
entier font part de leur détermination
d'en finir avec le sida au cours de la
décennie
l'objectif d'éradication en 2030 il est
atteignable
il est atteignable si aujourd'hui nous
sommes au rendez vous de nos
responsabilités aujourd'hui nous nous
fixons un nouvel objectif éradiquer la
transmission du vih ou angleterre d'ici
aucune nouvelle infection cours de la
prochaine décennie faisons du royaume
uni un des premiers pays à atteindre
l'objectif zéro infection de l'onu d'ici
de quel objectif zéro infection par le
ton en 2015 suite à de longues
négociations l'assemblée
de l'onu adoptent l'agenda 2030 à
l'unanimité dix sept objectifs de
développement durable que la planète
entière doit atteindre en 15 ans parmi
eux le résultat 2-0 contamination par le
vih à l'horizon 2030 pourtant avant d'
éradiquer complètement la maladie le nu
se fixe d'abord l'objectif 90 90 90
alors où en est on aujourd'hui plus de
cinq ans après l'annnonce de cet
objectif detroit 90 selon les dernières
données de l'onu 79% des personnes
vivant avec le vih connaissent leur état
en 2010 est toujours loin du but cette
proportion constitue pourtant le
meilleur score jamais atteint
pareil pour les porteurs du vih grosse
vente traitement antirétroviral
ils sont 78% aujourd'hui soit une hausse
de 10% depuis 2015
parmi ceux qui suivent un traitement
médical 86% atteignent la suppression de
la charge virale
les régions les plus proches de cet
objectif sont actuellement l'europe de
l'ouest et l'amérique du nord qui font
des progrès remarquables en matière de
lutte contre le vih à l'échelle mondiale
les tendances générales sont pourtant
mitigées d'un côté depuis 2015 le nombre
de nouvelles personnes contaminées par
le vih a diminué de 10% en 2018 ce
chiffre plafonné à 1,7 million de
personnes le nombre de morts du vhb sous
la barre d'un million depuis 2013 et
continue de baisser mais d'un autre côté
le nombre de personnes vivant avec le
vih continue d'augmenter en 2018
elles étaient plus de 37 9 millions soit
une hausse de 6,5 pour cent depuis 2015
encore plus alarmant est le fait que
plus de 8 millions de personnes
contaminées ne savaient pas qu'elles
vivaient avec le vih
en 2018 une conséquence directe de
l'insuffisance du nombre de diagnostics
du vih le chemin vers le zéro sida d'ici
dix ans ne sera donc pas facile et c'est
surtout vrai pour l'afrique
la région la plus touchée par le vih
c'est ici que vivent plus de deux tiers
de séropositifs dans le monde soit 25,7
millions de personnes la pauvreté
grandissante et les conflits armés qui
limite fortement l'accès aux traitements
contre le vih ne font qu'aggraver cette
situation l empire encore plus avec les
inégalités entre les sexes et les
violences sexuelles qui rendent les
jeunes femmes plus vulnérables au vih en
afrique subsaharienne
quatre nouvelles infections sur cinq
parmi les adolescents concerne les
filles
malgré l'ampleur inédite du problème
certaines avancées voit quand même le
jour depuis 2010 de moins en moins de
nouveaux cas sont enregistrés sur le
continent africain
pourtant le nu s'alarme d'une tendance
inverse qui est en train de se produire
en europe de l'est et du sud et en asie
centrale
même si dans ces régions le nombre de
porteurs du vih est plus faible qu'en
afrique on constate malgré tout une
forte augmentation des nouveaux cas
d'infection
rien qu'en 2010 850 mille personnes ont
découvert leur séropositivité soit une
hausse de 25% par rapport à 2010 c'est
le rythme le plus rapide d'expansion du
vih au monde
les nouvelles les plus alarmantes
viennent du monténégro de la macédoine
du nord de la bosnie herzégovine où le
nombre de nouvelles infections ont
augmenté de plus de 50% par rapport au
début des années 2010 les décès liés au
sida eux aussi augmentent dans la région
le du sida en a comptabilisé 38 milles
en 2018 soit 5% de plus qu'en 2010 par
exemple
en revanche la russie qui compte le plus
grand nombre d'individus vivant avec le
vih dans la région renverse la tendance
en 2019 pour la première fois depuis les
années 90 les autorités russes parlent
d'une baisse du nombre de nouveaux cas
d'infection
face à l'ampleur du problème la
communauté internationale ne reste pas
les bras croisés d'où vient la maladie
comment le nuc ont-elles combattre le
fléau du sida pourquoi malgré des
décennies de
l'ugtt la victoire on est toujours pas à
l'horizon la réponse après la pause
[Musique]
plus d'un million de nouvelles
infections et des centaines de milliers
de morts chaque année le vih continue à
gagner du terrain
de son côté l'onu semble déterminé à
mettre fin à la maladie mortelle d'ici
10 ans un objectif plus qu'ambitieux
compte tenu du fait que la lutte contre
ce fléau
ce plancher depuis plus de trente ans
les années 1920 c'est au congo belge la
rdc aujourd'hui que le vih serait
apparue selon l'hypothèse dominante
avancée par des chercheurs belges et
anglais entre 1930 1950 le virus
commence alors à se propager depuis le
congo vers les pays voisins
1960 après son indépendance le congo
belge devient un bassin d'emploi
attractif pour les francophones comme
pour les haïtiens
ces derniers de retour dans leur pays
aurait transporté le virus vers la côte
ouest de l'atlantique aux états unis
dans les années 70 alors que la
libération sexuelle bat son plein aux
états unis le virus s'y propage et se
multiplient dès lors aux quatre coins du
monde
ce n'est qu'en 1981 que le virus est
porté à l'attention du public
la communauté homosexuelle américaine
est alors frappé par une nouvelle
maladie qui frappe le système
immunitaire
elle est d'abord considéré comme
l'appellation saugrenue de cancer gay
mais les scientifiques réalise vite que
le virus est aussi dangereux pour les
autres bêlant la propagation du virus
devient un sujet d'inquiétude planétaire
1982 la maladie a désormais un nom sida
pour syndrome d'immunodéficience acquise
le 20 mai 1983
une équipe de chercheurs de l'institut
pasteur en france isole un virus lave
qui pourrait être impliquée dans le sida
plus tard ce virus sera rebaptisé vih ou
virus de l'immunodéficience humaine
cependant on ne connaît pas encore les
modes de transmission
c'est en 1985 que les scientifiques
constatent que le vih se transmet à
travers les fluides corporels à savoir
le sang le sperme et le lait maternel en
1987 les pays européens tels que la
france et la grande bretagne notamment
adobe des campagnes publicitaires choc
afin de sensibiliser les populations
contre le sida en 1987 le ms officialise
l'appellation du vih puis elle crée le
programme mondial de lutte contre le
sida
au même moment l'assemblée générale des
nations unies incite tous les pays
membres à lutter activement contre le
virus toujours la même année un
traitement antirétroviral à z t voit le
jour il empêche le virus de se propager
et permet de combattre les infections
liées au sida
c'est une avancée scientifique majeure
mais il est coûteux et présente des
effets secondaires il ne guérit certes
pas la maladie mais cela donne tout de
même de l'espoir dans la lutte contre la
maladie
1995 l'onu sida écrit le programme est
destiné à coordonner l'action des
différentes agences spécialisées de
l'onu pour lutter contre la pandémie
à ce moment le nombre de séropositifs
dans le monde et d'environ 17 millions
le premier traitements de trithérapie
voit le jour en 1996 il ne permet pas
d'éliminer complètement le virus mais
permet de contrôler l'infection et
d'augmenter l'espérance de vie des
malades
à partir des années
me les membres de la communauté
internationale investissent à l'échelle
nationale et internationale dans des
programmes d' aide financière afin de
prévenir la propagation du virus en
particulier dans les pays d'afrique
le nombre de personnes contaminées reste
quand même très élevé et en 2004
l'épidémie a atteint son pic
avec 1 million 700 mille morts cette
année là en 2007 un patient séropositif
connu sous le nom de patients de berlin
ne montrent plus de signes de la maladie
il avait bénéficié d'une greffe de
moelle avec des cellules d'un donneur
génétiquement résistant au vih en 2012
un autre traitement vient s'ajouter
contre la transmission du vih
le premier traitement préventif dit
prête et commercialisé aux états unis
il permet de réduire les risques de
contracter le vih 2018
face au traitement et prévention
médicale le nombre de morts du sida dans
le monde a été divisé par deux depuis
2004 en 2019 à l'instar du patient de
berlin un nouveau cas le patient de
l'ombre connaît une rémission durable la
menace que représente le vih pour le
monde est loin d'être jugulées pourtant
la réponse mondiale manque toujours de
vigueur en 2016 l'assemblée générale de
l'onu s'accordent sur la hausse
progressive des contributions des pays à
l'onu sida programme international pour
lutter contre la pandémie
l'engagement annuelle devait atteindre
pour moi 26 milliards de dollars
pourtant trois ans après l'onu sida tire
la sonnette d'alarmé selon les chiffres
publiés en 2010 9 son budget montrent
légèrement en 2017 mais chutent de
nouveau 2 1 milliards en 2018 si les
investissements restent inchangés
jusqu'en 2020 cette année-là il manquera
au programme 7 milliards de dollars
nécessaires pour la prévention et le
traitement une perspective plus
qu'inquiétante
le monde ne peut pas se permettre de
reculer quant aux investissements à
réaliser face au sida
pays doivent honorer leurs promesses
d'accroître progressivement leurs
investissements si le monde doit
respecter ses obligations face aux plus
vulnérables et aux plus démunis si les
chiffres pour 2010 9 ne sont pas encore
disponibles
cet appel semble tout de même être
entendus en effet en octobre à lyon
plusieurs pays ont confirmé leur
engagement contre le sida
la sixième édition de la conférence de
restitution du fonds mondial de lutte
contre le sida la tuberculose et le
paludisme est un succès 14,02 milliards
de dollars sont promis par les donateurs
sur les trois ans qui viennent
c'est un milliard de plus que lors de la
dernière conférence en 2016 un résultat
dû largement aux efforts des manuels
macron hôte de l'événement entend ce
campagne de lobby contribution renforcée
de la france bill gates et bono en co
animateur les moyens sont au rendez-vous
pour convaincre les capitales mondiales
pourtant le financement n'est pas le
seul obstacle à se dresser sur la route
vers les objectifs des 3 90 sans parler
des zones en guerre où les services
médicaux sont difficiles d'accès c'est
souvent par peur de stigmatisation que
des personnes infectées préfère ne pas
passer des tests en effet dans
l'imaginaire de certaines cultures le
vih et le sida sont associés avec des
phénomènes tabou ou même illégaux
souvent la voie sexuelle est perçue
comme la seule voie de contamination
possible ce qui n'est pas le cas les
malades creek donc des répercussions sur
leur réputation et leur cercle social
surtout dans les cultures
traditionnelles
par ailleurs
l'homosexualité est encore illégal dans
71 pays surtout en afrique ou en asie où
elle est souvent désigné comme
responsable de l'épidémie
les personnes infectées refuse donc
souvent les tests pour éviter une
sanction pénale allant jusqu'à la peine
de mort des dizaines de pays ont même
des lois discriminatoires contre les
séropositifs
il pénalise la transmission du virus ou
en pose des limites sur les déplacements
des personnes infectées allant jusqu'à
la déportation des malades est la
réponse à ce problème est théoriquement
simple il faudrait mieux informés sur
les voies de transmission du virus est
le vrai niveau du danger ce travail est
en cours au niveau global et local
pourtant que faire si l'information est
disponible mais que la population refuse
d'y croire
en effet certaines personnes refusent le
lien entre le vih et le sida et se
désignent eux-mêmes comme dissident ce
mouvement se répondent surtout dans les
années 90 et 2000
y compris dans des pays développés comme
les états unis où l'afrique du sud dont
une partie du gouvernement
relais à l'art cette thèse cette
dissidence autoproclamé connaît pourtant
déclin après une série de morts parmi
des militants eux-mêmes touchés par le
virus
pourtant le phénomène reprend de
l'ampleur dans certains pays et surtout
en russie
il se répand à travers les réseaux
sociaux des groupes consacrés à la
négation de l'existence du virus ont des
dizaines de milliers de followers et les
conséquences de cette idéologie sont
bien entendu désastreuse selon un groupe
de militants qui combattent ce phénomène
en russie plus de 100 adeptes ce
négationnisme et leurs enfants seraient
morts en russie depuis 2015
le phénomène attire même l'attention du
gouvernement fin 2019 le ministère russe
de la santé propose d'interdire la
propagation d'informations ni en
l'existence du vih
un des arguments qui nourrit ses
théories du complot et l'absence de cure
efficace à 100% contre le virus en effet
la thérapie antirétrovirale n'élimine
pas complètement le virus et doit être
administré tout au long de la vie elle
permet pourtant d'éviter le pire pour de
nombreux patients cependant en le
faisant elle crée un autre facteur de
risque pour les personnes saines en
effet selon la société internationale
sur le sida
cette solution thérapeutique présente le
d
faux de détourner les efforts de la
prévention primordial pour vaincre
l'épidémie
si nous faisons avancer la prévention là
où on en a le plus besoin et à l'échelle
nécessaire nous pouvons fortement
réduire le nombre de nouvelles
infections dans le monde entier
mieux vaut prévenir que guérir certes
mais est il possible de mettre fin à une
épidémie sans un vrai remède l'effort
mondial commun va-t-il ne portait aux
objectifs des 3,90 en 2020 comment être
sûr de nos progrès quand de mauvaises et
de bonnes nouvelles sur le vih se
côtoient tous les jours pour mieux
comprendre où nous en sommes sur la voie
d'un monde sans sida
nous rejoignons and sénéquier chercheuse
associée
aleris madame seddiki et ces dernières
années le nu enregistre une baisse du
rythme d'expansion du sida en afrique
même si c'est là que vivent les deux
tiers des porteurs de ce virus en même
temps l'europe de l'est région à
condition de vie plus favorable
démontrent une tendance inverse la
maladie continue à y gagner du terrain
pourquoi ce paradoxe selon vous alors ce
sur cette différence finalement on va
avoir ce paradoxe qui est présent mais
qui malgré tout prouve que l'argent mis
sur la table ne suffit pas et qu'on a
une vraie problématique
on ressent un petit peu ce dont parlait
en première partie de l'émission sur les
problématiques sociétales en afrique
aujourd'hui on va avoir justement un
travail sur une approche communautaire
c'est-à-dire un dépistage un accès aux
traitements et un accès aux conseils et
à la prise en charge la suite qui en
train d'être développé et qui fonctionne
c'est à quelques et quelques études qui
ont été faits au kenya où finalement en
l'espace de deux ans seulement cet
objectif 89 90 90 a été largement
atteints dans dans ses études sur sur
toutes les communautés présentes
on a aussi des pays par exemple comme le
botswana qui vont prendre leurs
problématiques justement savoir où
résident les foyers
épidémique en permettant aux résidents
étrangers d'avoir accès à la gratuité du
traitement contre le vih en dépénalisant
l'homosexualité et du coup on va
justement avoir une meilleur accès aux
soins et c'est justement là où on a une
problématique avec l'europe de l'est et
ils ukraine et monténégro de ça où on a
finalement encore une très forte
stigmatisation des populations clés dont
nous parlions tout à l'heure et et c'est
un problème donc cette partie de la
population
on n'a pas n'a pas accès aux soins
et lorsque justement ils vont pouvoir
aller malgré tout chercher des soins on
a aussi une difficulté pour trouver que
ce soient des professionnels de la santé
qui ne vont pas être dans le jugement
qui ne vont pas faire un report et ainsi
de suite
et c'est vrai que par exemple lors des
jeux de sotchi
finalement il ya eu beaucoup de
discussions sur la communauté lgbt dit
que tout allait bien se passer
et en même temps on avait des
informations comme quoi toute
manifestation qui promouvait qui promeut
le
les comportements homosexuels seraient
interdits finalement donc d'un côté on a
une petite ouverture de l'autre côté on
a toujours cette interdit sociétale et
c'est la problématique c'est là le la
chose la plus compliquée à faire ça va
être le changement de comportement et ça
c'est pas juste travailler sur les
populations cibles c'est travailler sur
la population générale et faire passer
les bons messages autant en termes de
lois que en termes d'acceptation dans la
vie de tous les jours dans les écoles
dans les hôpitaux dans les autres
travaillent
si tu étais un situer donc ça c'est
c'est vraiment il ya ce besoin de
travailler sur les valeurs
d'acceptation de la société et ça
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on ait évoqué
tout à l'heure ce maillon faible qui
persistent et qui finalement sera aussi
présent en afrique mais pour l'instant
comme en afrique on a cette capacité
d'avoir encore quelques coups et queen
et d'accès aux soins
mais finalement sur les chiffres ça se
ça se répercute différemment merci merci
beaucoup merci encore madame senequier
je rappelle vous êtes chercheuse
associée à layrisse merci d'avoir
apporté votre éclairage dans cette
émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]